the challenge around sustainability is
it's impossible how does your impact so
the question then becomes how do you
minimize impact and how do you do things
yourself that can help people live more
sustainably one of the brightest
newcomers to the auto scene is ready an
automotive led by charismatic CEO RJ
scarrans the company will start building
vehicles by the end of this summer but
do they have the potential to disrupt
the IDI market we shall see Tesla has
had a monopoly for almost a decade and
now with ribbing coming out the end of
the summer they truly have competition
and more choice which is really what
will drive the growth of v's going
forward when you look at the truck or
SUV space today the vehicles we see
people buying are requiring some level
of compromise so they're requiring
compromise on fuel economy or efficiency
they typically require a trade-off
between on-road dynamics or off-road
dynamics and what we wanted to create
was a solution in a product that really
answered both sides meaning it highly
efficient but still really high
performance really capable on-road buts
they're really capable off-road and what
that required of us was to rethink and
really approach the platform quite a bit
differently a lot of the work that's
gone into the drivetrain in the in the
chassis and the electronics are on that
enable that really unique driving
experience
the skateboard has been around for a
long time Raveena has one of the most
elegant skateboard basically is
everything that you need to drive the
vehicle on one chassis so it's the
chassis the electric motors that will
drive the wheels battery pack and also
all the computing power that you need
what makes ribbons escape word different
from the rest is flexibility
everything can be configured to your
needs as a company as an automaker and
that's what Raveena is doing with it we
fortunately focused so much of our
efforts on making sure the guts the
foundation of the business the
technology the team was really robust so
as we've now brought on really
sophisticated partners and some you know
highly sophisticated financial investors
when they look at the business they see
the depth of work that's gone into
building it so it certainly made the
process of bringing on those types of
partners and securing that kind of
capital a lot more straightforward
we traveled to Normal Illinois to visit
the future site of Ravens assembly plan
the 2.6 million square-foot facility is
now undergoing a 750 million dollar
renovation through plans to go into
production by the end of the summer so
this used to be a Miss efficient
manufacturing facility at its peak
proofs close to 250,000 units miss
efficient gasoline-powered vehicles
we're now in the process of converting
it from plant approves small gasoline
cars to a plant that produces a wide
variety of larger electric vehicles of
course our vehicles as well as vehicles
for Amazon as part of a program we have
with them at the heart of the deal
between Riven and Amazon is an electric
delivery van it will help Amazon to
achieve its zero carbon initiatives by
2030 partnering with such a giant like
Amazon gives you cred
what does this company have it's gonna
make a guy like Jeff Bezos write up a
check and say build me a hundred
thousand vehicles most automakers have
said that they are going to put out an
electric vehicle but Tesla and Riggins
seem to be the two real players right
now we hope to help provide another
option in a different perspective on
what a vehicle can be and a perspective
on what an electric vehicle can be and
it's great to see more people both
consumers and producers thinking really
creatively about what a vehicle can
become and what what it looks like in a
world of an electrified architectures
and then we're excited to be part of
that
you